then store our aqua present tiara Nobel
Prize Dharam official Gil le medicine it
is a great honor to introduce the Nobel
laureate in Physiology or medicine
professor Michael rosebush
[Applause]
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
excellencies fellow laureates ladies and
gentlemen on behalf of professors Mike
Young Jeff Hall and myself I want to
express our profound gratitude to the
Nobel assembly of the Karolinska
Institute and the Nobel foundation we
are being honored for our contributions
to the field of circadian rhythms for
our studies of the genes and mechanisms
that underlie this 24-hour timekeeper
the same biological clock ticks away in
humans and fruit flies which underscores
the importance of circadian timing to
life on this planet indeed we now know
that this clock affects almost all
aspects of human physiology all three of
us began our professional lives with the
love of laboratory and experiment and we
have worked almost exclusively with the
fruit fly Drosophila remarkably this is
the fifth Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine for this tiny insect beginning
in 1933 with the Pioneer th Morgan he
was also the first American to receive
this Nobel Prize this history that
underscores the importance of Drosophila
model organisms and basic research more
generally to scientific progress we
benefited from an enlightened post-war
period in the United States our National
Institutes of Health have
enthusiastically and generously
supported basic research although it
continues to be the essential foundation
for progress and more applied areas the
current climate in the u.s. is a warning
that continued support cannot be taken
for granted also in danger is the
pluralistic America into which all three
of us were born and raised after World
War two immigrants and foreigners have
always been an indispensable part of our
country including its great record in
scientific research eight of the ten
Nobel Science winners here today are US
citizens but four of us are immigrants
or children of immigrants we are
changing this successful formula at our
peril
I note that Sweden is the most refugee
friendly country in Europe if not the
world Scientific careers rely on
inheritance environment and random
events like all biological phenomena our
inheritance includes Diaries from
traditional Drosophila genetics and for
the school of fly behavior that Seymour
Benzer and his students began at Caltech
in the mid 60s most important for the
circadian field was the pioneering work
of Ron Konopka in Seymour's lab speaking
of Seymour the three of us received from
several colleagues on October 2nd by
email the same words that he sent by
telegram to his to French his three
French friends winners of the Nobel
Prize in Physiology or medicine in 1963
Moshiach Oleg please accept my sincere
condolences on the occasion of your
being forced to share this Nobel Prize
with those other two jerks when in my
opinion you alone fully deserve it our
environments have been unfailingly
supportive and we are profoundly
indebted to our families colleagues
students and postdocs as well as to our
remarkable institutions Brandeis
University the Howard Hughes Medical
Institute and the Rockefeller University
lastly one should never discount the
importance of blind dumb luck as we have
been blessed with good fortune at almost
every turn yet to have this journey
topped off in this way is almost
unimaginable Mike Jeff and I are honored
beyond words thank you
you